Democrats and some Republicans are
speaking out against president Trump's
racist tweets about for democratic
congresswoman House Democrats introduced
a resolution condemning the president's
comments mr. Trump told the lawmakers
who are women of color and American
citizens to go back to their countries
the house could vote today on that
resolution so far at least 28
Republicans have criticized the
president's words yesterday the four
congresswoman apparently targeted by the
president he didn't name them
specifically slammed his comments as
racist this morning on Twitter President
Trump accused the group of saying some
of the quote most vile hateful and
disgusting things ever said by a
politician he said the house should vote
to rebuke them Abram Kennedy is a
professor and director of the
anti-racist research and Policy Center
at American University in Washington DC
he's made the trip to join us at the
table here in New York good morning good
to see you morning professor Kennedy you
know take us to the history about go
back to where you came from
why is that considered a racist
statement I know it made a lot of people
cringe when he said it well in the 19th
century there were many many reformers
racial reformers who thought that the
way to solve the race problem the Negro
problem was essentially send back all
free blacks and that started with Thomas
Jefferson his notes of the state of
Virginia which was published in 1787 and
and went all the way up to Abraham
Lincoln and it's never said about
Caucasians or white people of European
descent is it ever it is not because
it's assumed that this is their country
and so where would they go back to
people of color it's assumed that this
is not their country as we reported some
of the president's supporters have
called his tweets inappropriate not
racist what do you say to that what
first that's it there's no such thing as
not racist
there's racist and anti-racist and and
racist idea suggests that there's
something wrong or right superior or
inferior about a particular group it
suggests that there's something
inherently normal about white Americans
that Americans are white and whites are
Americans and his idea suggests that
somehow people of color are not American
that's deeply racist but professor I
heard one of his supporters say they
they're not racist because in the tweets
he never mentions race so how can it be
so I heard someone say he never mentions
race how could it be considered racist
so poll taxes grandfather clauses these
were voting suppression bills that are
widely considered by Americans today to
be racist but there were no racial
language in them you don't have to have
racial language in in an idea or even in
a policy for it to be racist it's about
what its outcome are you suggesting that
there's something wrong with a
particular group are you Lee or is it
creating inequity that's the true
measure of whether something is racist
what role do Republicans play in sort of
checking the president about these
comments you hear them say it's
unacceptable it's divisive it's you know
people are frustrated but some of them
are not really calling out this behavior
is racist what role do they play and
sort of helping move this conversation
forward or get a better understanding of
how our president can say that and some
people really feel like that's not
offensive I think Republicans should
play the same role as all Americans and
that is to identify racism when you when
they see it and to say that America is
not going to stand for it and this is a
bipartisan issue this is an issue that
cuts across lines either we're a nation
of immigrants either we're a nation
where everyone is included or were a
nation of white people and and I think
we have to decide and Republicans need
to decide what type of nation are they
going to stand up for the White House
says the president has repeatedly
condemned racism and bigotry in all
forms so every group of racists in
American history have condemned bigotry
and racism in all forms except their
form right so slaveholders condemned it
segregationists condemned it mass
incarcerate is condemned it they all
condemn it but they all deny their own
racism that's essential to racism itself
Congressman Ilhan Omar has come under
fire for some of the remarks he made
that she said people say some
anti-semitic and divisive and divisive
things should she be criticized you see
her the comparison between her when
and what the president said in the st.
is the same I do not why and she was
very specific in criticizing the
policies of a country in this case the
country was Israel Trump has
specifically criticized racial groups of
people well when he said that Mexicans
are rapists when he said that black
people that a trait of blacks is is
laziness this is a combination of a
racial group of people that is
effectively racism when we criticize a
country's policies that is not when you
criticize Israeli policies that's not
anti-semitic but when you say there's
something wrong with Jews that is and I
haven't heard or say that
can you write racist things and say
racist tweets and not be a racist what
you do in terms of what you say what
policies you support determines whether
you're being racist or anti-racist so no
if you say things that are racist you're
racist just like if you say things that
are anti-racist the next minute you're
being an anti-racist what we do is is
effectively who we are in that moment
and the people that don't criticize them
do you can credit criticize those
remarks are they racist because I've
heard people say well I like his
policies I don't like that he said that
but I like some of this policy so when
you have a politician who is
mass-producing and circulating racist
ideas racist ideas as to someone's I
just described saying that that that
immigrants from the south are are
criminals but never says anything is
about immigrants from from Europe or
even the north when you have someone who
says these things and you don't
challenge them you're effectively
supporting them yourself you're
effectively being racist yourself all
right Dean Brown Kennedy thank you so
much for being with us this morning it's